[Music]
on this episode of travel dare season us
i'll be playing a different tune as i
learn an iconic craft in america's music
city
[Music]
last episode i got a clue for where to
end up on this episode time to build
music in the city so now i'm here at
moxie nashville downtown the only hotel
on honky tonk row nashville is also
known as the songwriting capital of the
world and today i get to try my hand at
the local craft of guitar making
i am so excited for this guitar build
workshop as someone who loves music i
can't wait to make the guitar
hey i'm jenna hi jenna i'm josh hey josh
to the workshop thanks for having me how
long have you been doing this this is
our ninth year here and what motivated
you to open this place well i moved to
nashville and i made guitars and i know
how exciting it is to make guitar so i
decided to teach people how to build
guitars how do the different elements of
the guitar affect the final product like
the tone in terms of the the shape the
material all of that there's a whole
bunch of things that affect the sound
that the electronics affect the sound
the wood affects the sound there's a
whole bunch of things it's just like
cooking if you add a little extra
something to your chocolate chip cookies
right they're gonna taste different but
they're still gonna be awesome so what
do you think makes this course so unique
we do everything in one day
nobody in the world can build a guitar
in one day but somehow we've been able
to condense everything into six to eight
hours i think i'm ready to get started
i'm so excited let's make some sawdust i
got an apron for you ah is that my name
that is your name i love this so much
josh i feel like this is the beginning
of a beautiful friendship
all right jenna ready to get started yes
all right the first step that we're
gonna do is we're gonna sand the guitar
bodies okay
now we have to sand the guitar body nice
and smooth so the wood is smooth and
will absorb the stain a lot better so we
are going to sand the front face first
we're going to use the sander for about
two minutes on this we're going to flip
it over and do the exact same thing on
the back side
[Music]
the next thing that we're going to do is
we're going to sand the edges
and we just go with the grain a little
bit
until it's nice and smooth
now that we're done here do you want to
go over to the laser engraver and add
some flair i love flare excellent let's
go then okay
[Music]
there it is
that's awesome
all right jenna yeah the next step is
staining the guitar body
this is the finish that you've chosen
this is a three-tone faded sunburst the
recipe is on the back we're gonna use
three colors yellow red and a mahogany
now by the time you're done i guarantee
it's gonna look good
what do you think i think you did an
amazing job thank you congratulations
feeling really good about it so are you
ready to go on to the next step
excellent the first thing that we have
to do is we have to put the tuners onto
the guitar okay and after we've done
that then we start assembling all the
other hardware onto the guitar body okay
once that's all done we put the neck on
and then soon after we're gonna put
strings on and play let's get to it
[Music]
you did it the guitar is done it's done
so now we have to play it are you ready
yes okay welcome this way i got a
special guest for you in the other room
oh i can't wait to meet them excellent
[Music]
oh hey ooh hi
jenna this is nashville legend max t
barnes hey how are you hi it's so nice
to meet you yeah what'd you all do today
anything built a guitar can you believe
it well you built that yes the whole
thing start to finish is that right yeah
the color and everything stained it and
all this one is an amazing teacher
that's amazing good job it's gorgeous
guitar well welcome to nashville thanks
for having me they call it music city do
you know why i have no idea well the
lore goes that there's a insurance
company in the mid last century they had
a little radio show and they would have
local people come in and sing bluegrass
and country music and they would
broadcast that and one thing led to
another and it got too big for that so
they moved into this neat old church
downtown built in the 1800s called the
ryman auditorium and they still do
concerts there now and then they built
the grand ole opry house so that's how
that all got started because the
announcer would call this music city and
it stuck
well let's see how that thing works
shall we plug it in and please yes i'm
very excited to see how there you go
let's see
very good all right well
if you played a lot of electric guitar
i've never played an electric controller
maybe not well let me show you a few
things a few tricks and tips kid
here's how it goes well the first thing
you got to know is none of this matters
it's pretty much just all you got to get
that face on you know
you got to learn that face right now
yeah that's pretty good that's pretty
good maybe when you start playing a
little bit
you get your shoulder into it
[Music]
[Music]
big big ending ready yes you go
take your pick
that's it welcome to nashville you
graduated yes thanks for having me very
good
[Music]
my day at the guitar build workshop was
such an incredible experience i think my
favorite part was watching the assembly
of it and seeing it all come together it
was just so satisfying and i got to
build my own custom guitar felt like a
total rock star when you come to
nashville do yourself a favor venture
off broadway and give it a try yourself
here's your drink and clue i'll just
close out thanks
[Music]
oh final clue
let's see where we're going on our last
stop
check out these hoppy hot springs
i don't know why we're going to be
jumping a lot i'm not sure but i'm very
excited to find out
until next time
you